bonjour à tous voient ou et a présenté
aujourd'hui ses pépins et l impro et
justement on va en parler parce que vous
allez voir c'est très intéressant là
aujourd'hui on est en droit à un petit
peu différent je ne suis pas chez moi je
tourne la vidéo est quelque chose comme
23h18 grande journée oblige il ya plein
de choses à voir dessus et on va
regarder ça
aujourd'hui c'est le grand jour où on
veut présenter cp 20 et p20 pro alors le
père ait on a déjà parlé il ya quelques
temps aujourd'hui on va se recentrer sur
les p 20 ep20 pro sont vraiment deux
produits qui permettra à huawei de
continue de rester dans la course des
photophones et on se demande même est-ce
que huawei va avec le pépin pro à voir
le photophone 2018 c'est vraiment une
question hyper intéressante parce qu'on
a vu en fin d'année dernière que apple a
présenté son iphone dit ce qui est déjà
un excellent photophone il ya eu ensuite
l'arrivée des galaxy s 9 et as 9 plus ya
pas très longtemps et là avec le huawei
p20 pro le pépin c'est un peu autre
chose vraiment le b20 pro on va
continuer vraiment à se positionner dans
la guerre dans la guerre stratégique des
photophones avec un produit qui est
super sympa donc ce qu'on va faire dans
un premier temps c'est qu'on va regarder
un petit peu la fiche technique entre le
p 20 lep 20 pro le père a été sorti
aussi mais j'en ai parlé déjà il ya pas
très longtemps la vidéo se trouve juste
là vous pouvez aller la voir
le p 20 le père un pro sont vraiment des
produits qui sont quand même nettement
supérieur mais surtout le p 20 pros et
on a foncé dessus alors point de vue
fiche technique
j'ai mes petites notes je vais regarder
déjà les deux produits tourne sous
android
8.1 oreo avec une surcouche maison m88
points ils ont tous les deux un karine
970 boosté à l'intelligence artificielle
cadencé à 2,36 gigahertz
si giga de ram pour le p 20 pro 4 gigas
de ram pour le p 20 tous les 228 giga de
stockage non extensible ne cherchez pas
à vouloir rajouter un peu plus de
stockage avec une carte micro sd pour
coup là ce n'est pas possible
bon sang nature giga normalement vous
devez pouvoir en mettre déjà un petit
peu alors l'écran fait déjà la
différence vous avez d'un côté un écran
6,1 pouces oled fhd plus 1080p au format
18 points 7/9 pour le p 20 pro et un
écran 5,8 pouces lcd format 18 points
7/9 pour le p 20 l'autre grosse
différence au niveau des appareils photo
et c'est vraiment le point qui nous
intéresse le plus pour le pépin pro vous
avez 3 capteur photo à l'arrière mais
c'est la surenchère il y en a eu il ya
peu et maintenant il y en a trois vous
avez un capteur 40 millions de pixels
couleurs avec une ouverture de f 1.8
alors pourquoi 40 millions pixels
parce que en faible luminosité vous
allez utiliser quatre pixels pour faire
un seul pixel il
pères lumineux ça vous fera donc un
appareil de 10 mégapixels mais avec une
superbe luminosité et ça ça va être
intéressant vraiment ce que les
conditions de lumière contre est très
basse alors j'ai gardé une différents
tests j'ai lu différentes choses citant
des médias très intéressant et
effectivement il partager une
information disant qu' ils ont pu le
tester dans des conditions il n'y avait
vraiment pas de lumière il arrivait
quand même à capter des informations
donc je pense que le p 20 pro qu'on va
tester très prochainement donc rester
connecté abonnez-vous je pense vraiment
que c'est un pro va vraiment nous se
reprendre après quel intérêt d'aller
faire des photos dans le noir ou alors
ce qui a vraiment pas beaucoup de
lumière
je ne suis pas sûr qu'ils ont énormément
mais en attendant c'est parmi vraiment
d'avoir un comparatif notamment avec les
samsung galaxy s 9 et n est plus vous
avez également un capteur photo de 20
mégapixels monochrome cette fois ci avec
une ouverture f 1.6 et un capteur 8
mégapixels téléphoto téléobjectif avec
une ouverture de f 2.4 pour le p 20 vous
avez un double objectif 1 20 mégapixels
monochrome avec une ouverture de f 1.6
et 1 12 mégapixels couleurs avec une
ouverture de f 1.8 vous inquiétez pas il
fera très bien la faire si vous voulez
pas aller sur le p 20 pro vous pourrez
sur le p 20 vous aurez quand même un
appareil qui fera d'excellentes photos
que ce soit le pvp d'impro vous avez
l'avant en appareil photo de 24
mégapixels avec une ouverture de f 2.0
pour le père impro une batterie de 4 8
millions paire eur pour le pèlerin une
batterie de trois mille quatre cent
millions terreur dans les deux cas de la
recharge rapide
pas de port jack grosse déception mais
pas de port jack sur ces appareils
une certification ip67 pour le p 20
projets rien vu pour le p 20 mai ça me
surprendrait canepa et seul pépin pro
vous avez un zoom hybride x 5
ces deux modèles sont disponibles avec
une seule carte sim ou avec deux cartes
sim en fonction de vos besoins
ils sont disponibles en précommande dès
aujourd'hui le p 20 pro à 899 euros et
le p 20 à 649 euros qui dit grand écran
dit également encoches l'encoche
vraiment quelque chose qu'on retrouve de
plus en plus sur les smartphones android
effectivement on va très bien qui
s'inspire de la fameuse encoches de
l'iphone 10 alors je sais que beaucoup
vont me dire ce n'est pas apple qui a
mis en premier l'encoche mais en moi
c'est vraiment eux qui le démocratise et
qui vont continuer le démocratiser
donc on les prend malgré tout en
référence alors rassurez vous si vous
n'aimez pas les colonnes vous pouvez
complètement passé à travers et ne pas
utiliser ça vous fera une bordure noire
au niveau du capteur photo à l'avant
mais vous pouvez complètement ne pas
avoir d'encoches c'est possible tout ce
qu'a regretté le quator d'empreintes
digitales sur l'iphone 10 vous allez
retrouver cette fois ci directement sur
la façade soit sur le p 20 ou pépin pro
ou alors si vous en voulez à l'arrière
il faudra les sols pauvres light ou
alors sur les samsung galaxy s 9 et à ce
même plus maintenant la question à se
poser c'est que choisir entre d'un côté
l'iphone disent les galaxy s 9,9 plus et
l'épée 20 p 20 pro pour moi la toute
première chose sans pareil de
photographies de vouloir faire des
photos dans le noir la première question
à se poser c'est qu'elle produit allez
vous préférez du point de vue de l' os
ios android du point de vue la surcouche
la surcouche de samsung ou alors la
surcouche de huawei est ensuite est-ce
que vous avez préféré d'abord un capteur
d'empreintes digitales positionné à
l'avant
positionné à l'arrière et qu'elle
affinités vous avec le produit parce que
pour moi les trois sont quand même très
très très proches
vous allez avoir d'excellentes photos
chez samsung effectivement vous et avoir
une ouverture variable vous et pouvoir
aller jusqu en f1 points 5
alors qu'avec le peuvent improviser
l'est jusqu'à f 1.6 mais rassurez-vous
en faible luminosité ça fera très très
bien la faire vous n'avez pas utilisé
comme appareil professionnel et si de
toute façon volontaire du pro mieux vaut
aller sur un boîtier reflex donc de
toutes façons ne vous inquiétez pas dans
tous les cas vous aurez vraiment
d'excellentes photos
la question à se poser c'est l'affinité
marc loos le prix parce qu'il vraie
différence de prix il faut savoir quand
même que le pev impro se situe vraiment
au niveau tarif entre le galaxy s 9 et à
seneffe plus vous êtes à 899 euros alors
qu en s 9 plus coûte 959 euros
on parle même pas de l'iphone 10 à plus
de 1100 euros voilà peu pour ces tout
nouveaux produits alors rassurez vous on
va les prendre en main très bientôt on
va reparler y aura d'autres vidéos
dessus on va faire des comparatifs un
peu plus en détails
là je me devais de vous en parler la
vidéo va être publié d'ici 8 heures mais
c'était très important d'en parler
le jour de l'annoncé alors vous allez
voir dès demain on va parler d'autre
chose parce qu'elle pas eu uniquement
que huawei aujourd'hui on annonce il ya
aussi eu apple qui a présenté pas mal de
choses déchets au mieux on rester
connecté parce que tout ça on va
paraître très très rapidement dites moi
vous ce que vous en pensez
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ces
produits p 20 p 20 propre et 20 light
est ce que vous pourriez vous laisser
tenter ce qui vous intéresseraient est
ce que vous êtes déçu par le travail de
huawei est ce que vous êtes enthousiaste
et ce que pensent et qui vont dans le
bon sens et ce qu'il pensait que c'est
une vraie alternative par rapport à ce
qu'on a
galaxy s 9 s9 plus et l'iphone 10 mark
et moi tout ça en commentaire j'ai hâte
de les lire et de pouvoir y répondre
merci à vous à très bientôt portez vous
bien sûr les sages leur donnerait une
très très très très vite pour une
nouvelle vidéo
et puis les tests vont arriver
rapidement donc restez connectés à
bientôt à bientôt
ciao
[Musique]